let's talk about those tens of millions
of dollars
that donald trump raised after the
election
and before january 6th meant to
fight voter fraud in the courts
and met to support the republican
incumbent senators in georgia
both of whom lost donald trump
spent none of that money on the things
he claimed he was raising the money for
and of course anybody who looked at the
fine print as we did
would have predicted exactly this 76
million dollars
donald trump raised for what ultimately
was
a slush fund claiming i need the money
to challenge the results of the election
i need the money to make court filings i
need the money to help republicans win
in georgia so that republicans maintain
control of the senate
but through the end of 2020 not a
dime was spent on those causes maybe we
don't yet have reporting
for uh q1 spending maybe in those first
five days of january
trump spent some of the 76 million on
the things he promised to spend it on i
doubt it
he a a a republican familiar with the
fundraising
fundraising operation said quote he put
nothing back
he didn't care he put all this money in
the bank for his own legal fights
he never cared about george's races but
not only
that he didn't even spend the money on
vote
challenges and if you recall back when
trump was doing this
we showed you the fine print which said
uh
depending on which fundraising scheme we
were talking about
50 percent or even more of every dollar
raised
could go towards the trump campaign
general fund to pay off trump's campaign
debt
he said it i mean listen he said it in a
deceptive way
in the fine print sort of like a
software end user
agreement that's 30 pages long that
nobody reads right i mean but he did do
it
and we were reporting it and it was
reported so
completely predictable that this is
exactly what was going to happen
uh jason miller was asked what what
happened jason
where did the money go and jason miller
so far has not responded for comment
now the the truth is trump may well need
this money for his own legal defense
and i think it's absolutely disgusting
that he's taking advantage of his own
supporters who he clearly never cared
about his people
but ultimately it's scammers and more
scammers
and more scammers taking advantage of
people who
are often scammers in their own ways
people who were
delighted to be bamboozled by trump in
2016
and wanted to continue believing that
trump was somehow going to figure out
something even though he lost the
election
this was the right these were the
perfect marks to be bamboozled in this
way
and ultimately the money is going to the
save
america leadership committee of trump
this is nothing more than a slush fund
where the money can be used for just
about anything trump wants if trump
wants to pay himself a salary out of
this money
he could do it and um it is
unbelievable that these folks fell for
it hook line and sinker despite the fact
that we were widely reporting that this
is exactly what was going on
now when you say these people fell
victims to a scam and and we should feel
bad for them
i don't know about that um you know it
it it is these folks who say
oh we don't need a nanny state
government we don't need the government
protecting everybody from
everything all the time these are adults
in the end these are adults who
presumably voted for trump in 2016
and or 2020. these are adults who
despite the fact that there was no
evidence they fell for the idea that
trump actually won
and joe biden didn't they fell for i
mean look at look at everything that
they believe
at some point do they have any
responsibility themselves to figure out
what's true
they fell for the lie that donating to
trump might actually change the results
of an election even though
the election everything was happening on
schedule there were they said
oh uh december 14th is going to be
delayed and it wasn't
and then december what was you know
january 6 was going to be delayed and
the riots delayed it by a couple of
hours and it wasn't and then the
inauguration is not going
and it did they fell for it all do they
really deserve now to be bailed out
from the fact that they were scammed not
according to their own political
philosophy which is no nanny state
government
none of this stuff so everybody but his
cult
knew this would happen they are uh
they they it's hard to even call them
suckers because they were so willing
uh i i don't want to call it stockholm
syndrome i i don't know what to call it
but
um they i i have a hard time now uh
feeling as though they need to be
bailed out in some way because trump put
it at the bottom of the emails
it's how trump governed this was the
administration the scam
administration from day one and these
people got exactly what they voted for
which is trump ending up with i believe
it's
the 76 million i think it's 45 million
in some kind of joint rate fundraising
account
and then the other 31 million in that uh
defend america save america thing that
trump himself controls so
uh you know trump is going to do fine
financially very clearly
a lot of those folks who donated money
that they probably couldn't even really
afford to donate
may now have serious financial troubles
but they have only trump
and their own ignorance to thank for
that later by the way
we will talk about other other scams
that continue to
fester related to this administration
but the question
i have for you i want to hear from you
on twitter where you can find me at d
pacman should we feel bad for these
people who were swindled by trump's
fundraising
to the point that somebody should bail
them out i believe the answer is no
i'm willing to hear other ideas find me
on twitter
deepakman one of our sponsors today is
magic spoon the reason i'm such a fan of
magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of
protein so it's perfect for someone on a
low carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video